today we're going after the platinum
trophy for Lego Harry Potter years 5-7
and when I say this one surprised me
that wasn't always in a good way don't
get me wrong the game is really fun and
better than one through four in many
ways there are awesome new mechanics and
improvements to the gameplay plus you
get to travel to so many different
iconic Wizarding World locations that
you don't get to see at all in years one
through four as for the not so great
surprise well there was a trophy in
years one through four that I described
as one of the most button-mashingly
painful trophies I have ever seen
somehow they managed to take that idea
and make it much much worse in years
five through seven and I actually made a
pretty big mistake here that well oh and
we don't have it oh no please don't tell
me you have to actually do everything to
get it because I don't think we have a
character that can open no no there's
gotta be another way people love the
internet retro raconteur here I'm just a
dad who loves Platinum trophies and
right now I have 60 of them by the end
of this video I'm gonna have 69 before
any great trophy hunt you need to go in
with a strategy some would say a
platinum strategy yeah it just doesn't
sound nearly as good without what no
strategy there are 49 total trophies for
the PS4 version of the game which means
we need to collect 48 trophies to unlock
the Platinum estimated time to
completion around 30 hours step one
story you already know how this one go
wait hold on what's this there's a
highly miscible story trophy alert the
missable trophy is called Hogwarts has
changed for those who know the story of
Harry Potter book 7 is quite a bit
different considering much of it takes
place outside Hogwarts School the
primary setting for the first six books
so in addition to getting the regular
Story related trophies we also have to
make sure we secure this one we kick
things off with Harry Potter in the
Order of the Phoenix which opens with a
horde of Dementors attacking Harry and
his cousin Dudley oddly enough you don't
have access to some of the spells that
you ended year 4 with I get this was a
conscious decision probably due to
gameplay progression concerns but it
definitely felt off playing this one so
close to completing the previous game
fortunately we do still know expect to
patronum so they escaped the Dementors
but now Harry is in trouble for using
magic outside of school Dumbledore sends
a few members from the Order of the
Phoenix and we get an epic flying
sequence as they escort Harry to number
12 grimald Place honestly this opening
surprised me and this surprise was a
very good surprise this level alone
seemed far more ambitious than anything
I had seen in years one through four it
wasn't just the cool flying sequence
though you also get to play as a few
members of the order during that mission
such as future Minister for magic
Kingsley shackle bolt as well as the
real mad Eye Moody speaking of the
ministry we also take a trip there with
Mr Weasley Harry has a trial to explain
why he was using magic outside school as
an underage wizard the ministry itself
looks absolutely amazing the developers
really did an awesome job bringing this
location to life in Lego form and it's
here we're introduced to one Dolores
Jane Umbridge who has to be the most
hated character in the entire Harry
Potter series fortunately Dumbledore
shows up and keeps Harry from getting
into any serious trouble unfortunately
though the ministry places umbrage at
hogwart's in the role of defense against
the dark arts professor she also goes on
to Al's Dumbledore and become the
Hogwarts High Inquisitor but that
happens later she doesn't actually cause
as much trouble in the game as she does
in the book but they absolutely nailed
one of her most annoying mannerisms wait
for it
shut up shut up of course she enacts all
sorts of insane rules and here they
actually do have a story reason for
taking some of your spells away
so Harry and his fellow classmates
decide to form Dumbledore's Army and go
train on their own it's here we're
introduced to the new dueling mechanic
which wasn't present in the first game
you need to match the correct color
spell with your opponent get the wands
to connect and then Mash away on a
button to land a hit I think it's a
pretty fun addition but if I'm being
honest it was probably a little overdone
it just happens very very frequently
you'll see what I'm talking about here
as we go on Snape also starts teaching
Harry to prevent Voldemort from invading
his mind at least he attempts to do that
it doesn't go very well for either of
them but it does result in Harry
learning a new spell called Focus which
I'm pretty sure they invented just for
this game the spell lets Harry see what
someone is thinking anytime they have
this Cloud bubble above their head
casting focus on it reveals an item then
if you bring that item to the character
it will unlock something within the
level because of Harry's connection to
Voldemort he starts having visions that
reveal what the dark lord is up to in
one horrific Vision he Witnesses Mr
Weasley getting attacked by Voldemort
snake nagini eventually Umbridge does
find out about Dumbledore's Army but
Hermione comes up with a plan to lead
her into the Forbidden Forest where
Hagrid's giant brother Rob and a few
centaurs take care of the rest then
Harry and crew rushed to the ministry of
magic where Harry thinks his Godfather
Sirius is being tortured by Voldemort
all of this is because of another Vision
that he received only this time that
vision is fake turns out it was a ploy
by Voldemort to find out what's inside a
prophecy at the department of mysteries
the kids are attacked by Death Eaters
but the Order of the Phoenix arrives to
help
we have a dueling section here with
belgics or Lucius you actually get to
choose which one that you want to duel
no matter what though Bellatrix does
still send Sirius Beyond the Veil and
somehow Lego still manages to make it a
funny moment with their trademark humor
Dumbledore once again arrives at the
ministry just in time and we get an epic
duel between the two most powerful
Wizards currently alive this final
battle translated surprisingly well into
Lego form that included Voldemort's
giant snake made of fire and
Dumbledore's ore with water spell we get
two trophies here one for completing the
mission and another for completing your
5. this brings our total to 7 at this
point as we unlocked all these trophies
along the way one at the end of each
level unfortunately Half Blood Prince
felt like a big step down in terms of
the levels they weren't nearly as fun as
Order of the Phoenix and there just
wasn't much action here of course the
original story is mostly about
Dumbledore teaching Harry all he can
about the young Tom Riddle and while it
makes for a great book the Lego game
struggled to translate that into fun
gameplay moments the first level is
getting Slughorn to come out of
retirement they're basically just
rummaging through his house for a little
bit the second is the slug Club where
you get to clean up dishes then there's
Christmas at the Weasleys where you
actually get to wash clothes with Mr
Weasley I'm actually not kidding one of
the new mechanics introduced in years
five through seven though is the
quibbler dispenser which gives you a
pair of Specter specs these glasses
reveal hidden items you can interact
with in the level there's a trophy for
using one of these dispensers 25 times
so I found a dispenser inside Hogwarts
that was pretty easy to access and knock
that one out Harry and Draco duel in the
next mission and this is where Harry
uses sectum sempra for the first time
everything in years 6 builds to the
moment when Harry obtains the Felix
Felice's potion which helps him persuade
Slughorn to give up the memory of what
he told Tom Riddle about horcruxes this
sets up the final mission game with
Dumbledore and Harry venturing into a
cave in search of a horcrux you need to
force Dumbledore to keep drinking the
potion but you also have to use Harry to
fight off the approaching in theory I
was surprised by how much this section
really made me feel as if I was forcing
Dumbledore to keep drinking of course
it's much more traumatic in the books
but here in the game he'll stop and then
you have to switch back to him and make
him start drinking again I was really
disappointed in everything that came
after though the best part of the scene
is when Dumbledore gets to show how
incredibly powerful he is but in the
game it's just a very short cut scene it
was strange we didn't get to play as
Dumbledore at all during his fiery
moment of Glory especially when you
consider they did such a great job with
the duel against Voldemort to close out
Order of the Phoenix even so another
trophy added to the list for completing
the level and another for completing
year six this is something I was so
curious to see how the Lego games would
handle this because book Seven there's
so much happening so many different
locations and honestly I think they did
a pretty good job were introduced to a
new mechanic here thanks to Dumbledore
gifting the deluminator to Ron using it
for the first time gives us the lighten
up trophy like in year 5 Deathly Hallows
starts off with an epic departure from
the dursleys with six of Harry's friends
becoming a clone of him so they can
attempt to throw off Voldemort the real
Harry is paired up with Hagrid and he
leaves number four privet Drive the same
way he arrived all those years before
Harry and Hagrid escape from Voldemort
and closing out this Mission gives us
trophy number 17. at the end of this
level you also learn how to operate
which gives us another story related
trophy next the Death Eaters crash Bill
and fleur's wedding which sends the trio
out on their own for the horcrux hunt
the first stop is the ministry of magic
where they use polygi's potion to sneak
inside umbridge's office to retrieve
slytherin's locket Harry Ron and
Hermione are now on the run and have set
up camp so they can keep searching for
the other horcruxes okay remember that
miserable trophy now is the best time to
get it all we have to do is go back
inside the tent and interact with the
Marauders map this takes us back to
Hogwarts where we can see what's going
on with Jenny Neville and the rest of
the gang who are still in school Ron
leaves the group in frustration while
Harry and Hermione go to godrick's
hollow looking for answers and this sets
up what has to be one of the most
terrifying scenes in the entire series
and it's even pretty terrifying in the
Lego game you see at godrics Hollow they
meet the sweetest kindest just kidding
it's actually nagini wearing Matilda
backshot as a suit and they need to get
the heck out of there after just
narrowly escaping with their lives Harry
decides to follow a doe Patronus in the
forest as it reminds him of his mother
this leads him to the Sword of
Gryffindor which they need so they can
start destroying some of these horcruxes
Ron comes back just in time to help out
and then we get a scene I never thought
I'd seen a Lego game yeah your eyes are
not deceiving you that's Harry and Ron
swimming in their underwear freezing
cold water all to get the sword they
retrieve it together put their clothes
back on and then use the sword to put an
end to this piece of Voldemort's Soul
Harry and Hermione share a dance in the
tent and then we get one of the most
visually interesting levels that I've
ever seen in the Lego game if you
remember the tale of the Three Brothers
From the movie you'll know them with a
striking artistic interpretation of the
children's story that reveals the lore
of the Deathly Hallows the game follows
suit here and I thought it was
incredibly well done unfortunately the
gameplay isn't as fun as I was hoping
but it's still a nice change up from the
traditional formula shortly after
learning about the Hallows the trio are
captured and held hostage in Malfoy
Manor Dobby shows up to save the day but
unfortunately loses his life in the
process and that marks the end of part 1
bringing our trophy total to 26. deadly
Hallows Part 2 has some of the most
action-packed levels in the entire game
we get the grin got scene with the trio
sneaking not so subtly into bellatrix's
Vault to retrieve hufflepuff's cup then
we go back to Hogwarts and rally all of
the students who remain loyal to Harry
the next level is probably one of my
least favorite from Deathly Hallows at
this point the Death Eaters are
attacking the school and you need to set
up these explosive charges along the
bridge to try and buy Harry more time to
finish off those horcruxes I don't know
just something about it this level felt
very tedious to me just like in the
movie though there's a lot happening in
these final moments the next three
missions take us through the events of
fiend fire in the room of requirement
which destroys the diadem horcrux
Voldemort taking out Snape because he
ate the last cookie
oh
and then the final level with multiple
epic battles across Hogwarts they really
went all out for this final level as
you'll control several different
characters and get to play out many of
the iconic scenes including Neville
taking out nagini and Harry's final
showdown with Voldemort there's a super
quick epilogue at the end and we've now
completed all story missions for years
five through seven with the story
finished it's time for step two free
roam rather than immediately jumping
into the story missions again I decided
to take some time to explore Hogwarts
collecting gold bricks red bricks and
unlocking characters we need to make
sure we have a strength character dark
magic character and key character for
the replay anyway so it made more sense
to me to do that now this was a good
change of pace especially just after
wrapping up the story here we unlocked
the halfway there trophy for hitting 50
overall completion as I was searching
through daigon alley I stumbled into
borgon and Berks and actually found the
bonus level and here my fellow witches
and wizards is the moment when you have
to complete what is the most annoying
painful trophy of this entire game in
years one through four there were 10
bonus levels plus an additional level to
unlock Voldemort you could only access
this level though after collecting all
200 gold bricks but even then you didn't
unlock the character you had to play
through that whole level and collect 1
million studs by destroying things
around you all with no multiplier in
years five through seven there's only
one bonus level but my oh my it is
frustrating where's the Voldemort level
only took me about 15 minutes this one
took me over an hour to do once again
you're collecting studs without the
assistance of the red brick multipliers
but there's not as many things to smash
here instead you have to complete little
puzzles or switch to other characters to
make certain challenges possible and one
moment someone in my chat said this
remember that for later it doesn't get
here yeah remember I just stumbled into
this bonus level and thought sure why
not I'll go ahead and do it but I didn't
have a key character unlocked yet oh no
please don't tell me you have to
actually do everything to get it so if
there were only one million total studs
in this level to collect and I was
absolutely in trouble there was no way
that I could get past that lock at this
point I started frantically going all
over the level just destroying
everything I could and that's when I
remembered are we seriously stuck again
come on
yes yes it worked Patrick's like just
get in a van and RAM stuff with the
worst trophy out of the way it's time
for step three replay levels we need to
complete all 24 levels with the rank of
true wizard within each of these 24
levels we also need to rescue one
student in Peril snack four house crests
and find three character tokens I'll be
honest I was not fully prepared for how
long this was gonna take what I thought
would maybe be a few hours turned into a
grueling but epic eight hour adventure
to see it through to the very end
fortunately we unlocked the trophies for
collecting 1 billion studs and defeating
30 red caps my focus was to try and
complete each level just once without
having to go back a second time I did
much better than in years one through
four but there were still a few times I
would occasionally Miss and have to play
it over again it also didn't help that
many of the levels here are just longer
than the ones in the first game finally
though many many hours into the stream
we completed all levels but I still had
a problem I was missing quite a few
characters the character detector perk
from finding that red brick should show
us whenever we were near one so I
decided to go back through Hogwarts a
few times just to see if I could find
any no luck and that's what someone in
my chat said you can get back to the tin
area by operating from London across
from the Leaky cauldron so we knocked
those out and somehow we have 201 gold
bricks but still we were missing two
characters so I went back to Madame
malkans and bought every single
character that I currently had access to
this unlocked five trophies for us that
were all related to unlocking specific
groups of characters I did see we had
every version of Harry Potter unlocked
so I went ahead and completed the
challenge where you have to AK every
version of Harry using Voldemort a
little tedious but kind of humorous as
well and then by looking at the
remaining tokens on this menu we were
able to figure out the only two
characters I lacked or the fat fryer and
Justin Finch fletchley both were inside
Hogwarts and once I knew exactly where
to look they were easy enough to find
back to Madam alkins to buy them and
then we had successfully unlocked the
trophy for getting every member of the
Order of the Phoenix as well as the
trophy for completing the game to 100
finally with all characters accounted
for we can move on to step 4 challenges
we actually only have three here that we
did not get along the way first we need
to open a Weasley box with every member
of the Weasley family I was pretty sure
I had used Ron Arthur and Molly during
the story so I switched over to Jenny
Fred and George followed by Bill Charlie
and Percy to unlock the trophy both of
the final two challenges involve duels
with Bellatrix Lestrange the order
doesn't matter here but I needed to win
a duel against Bellatrix while using
Neville in the waiter outfit and then
another with Sirius in any outfit the
easiest level to do this on is the
Department of mysteries level from year
five yeah I totally could have done this
earlier if I'd had a better Platinum
strategy but by this point I knew the
level well enough that it didn't take
too long first Neville and then Sirius
which gives us our 61st platinum trophy
guys if you're a big fan of the Harry
Potter games then you should check out
this video next because I went on a
quest to buy every single one of them
big thank you to all our channel members
who helped make this possible if you'd
like to support us consider joining us a
channel member which gets you access
special emotes a special role in our
Discord and discounts on merch as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon